if you're talking about big Tech
election it was not a stolen election
you and your supporters lost more than
60 court cases on the election it's been
nearly two and a half years can you
publicly acknowledge that you did lose
the 2020 election let me just go on
camera on government cameras where they
were stuffing ballot boxes so with all
of that I think it's a shame that what
happened I think it's a very sad thing
for our country no I think Trump is
gone to our country our country has gone
to Hell our borders are bad our military
has been bad you look at the taxes you
look at inflation what's happened to
inflation it's just destroying our
country we've really become in many ways
a third world country and it's very sad
what's happened in this Administration
and it's uh something that we'll turn
around on day one we're energy
independent now energy is at a level
that we've never had to pay before we
nobody can afford to continue to pay
what's happening with energy